[Music]
thank you very much for joining us today
um i understand you've been a
psychiatrist for well over 20 years now
yeah in that time what has been the
greatest impact of your profession on
your personal outlook well let's start
with hackney itself i think you know i
mean remember hackney's in the east end
of london and it was to the north of
tower hamlets as it's called now and
it's always been the as it were the
first port of arrival the east end ever
since the historic docks for a lot of
you know people from different walks of
the world many of whom came as a result
of this strange thing called the british
empire which let's face it was a form of
geographical
uh
leverage to put it politely or luton
pillaged perhaps to be more honest
that offered a lot of promises to a lot
of people all over the world who came
here with varied degrees of hope and
disenchantment
and i think that has
very much marked the east end of london
quite unlike anywhere i'm not just
talking about black brown white here i'm
talking about huguenots ultra orthodox
jews i'm talking about kurds iraqis i'm
talking about the white british cockney
i'm talking about a whole series of
people who have always been somewhat
disenfranchised go to charles dickens
you know
so the east end is a pretty unique
melting pot really you'll see it to some
extent in south london but not quite the
same
you'll see it in brooklyn you'll see in
new york you'll see it in rio
but uh you know east london is an
astonishingly fascinating place to work
on top of all that we've got the
yapification and the squandering wealth
and the
crass selfishness of western
civilization
and i'll be blunt we're out to lunch on
the individual
we are shafted by our narcissism these
days
so i've seen hackney go from a very
vibrant and the estate agents put it
edgy otherwise dangerous
part of london that was also very
beautiful very dynamic and full of
people living alongside each other with
tolerance of respect
which incidentally have very powerful
antidepressant properties tolerance
respect and love are the best mood
stabilizers we've got
and i've seen it become more venal
posher house prices have shot up people
have been busted out to new and beyond
i've seen a significant whitening and
middle classic and yupification
i see london fields bearing a strong
resemblance to a penguin colony on
saturday afternoons full of chattering
people
and notice how they're all clumped by
their race and their class and a lot of
them are there because their parents are
paying for flats in the area
and all these people are cracking up in
their own private ways because child sex
abuse addiction schizophrenia depression
are never going to go away and they
never ever really particularly honed in
on the working classes except the fact
that the poor
are always much more the target of
sadness and despair for obvious reasons
we'd be a psychiatrist to know that
so what i've seen even like is a
a drift towards a different kind of
madness and sadness and badness
presenting in acne that reflects the
changing of the times
you might say that acne is kind of like
a mirror
in which we see
everything reflected
and we see greed and selfishness and
commercialization we see intelligence
and kindness still i'm not for a minute
saying that you know every single sort
of young
yuppie hippie smoking skunk grade
in london fields or scrolling down stoke
newton church street is necessarily a
dodgy character or not or selfish so
that sounds like in some ways you know
since you started out as a psychiatrist
we've almost taken some steps backwards
rather than forwards do you think that's
fair yeah i think we can say the same
for western civilization as a whole i
think we are very self-absorbed we don't
look quite as much towards community as
we do
the nuclear family is is not as common
as an or a valuable thing church isn't
to some extent
uh the trade unions have pretty much
gone to the wall i think the idea of
sharing
i think um
eric cobb's born and
david uh chappie wrote that
i'm afraid i can't remember his name
he's superb right left-wing historian
who wrote
the the the death of the public decline
of the public i think it was his name
it'll come to me in a minute
uh he made the observation that
the the last
sort of maybe the time from about 1830
1840 through to 1970 was a blip
in the history of human civilization
where for a while we actually put our
own needs behind those of other people
the germans invented social work and
paid leave we had kindness and care and
public transport public spirit public
institutions and organizations and for a
long time this as we say aberration led
to kindness and tolerance being the norm
you didn't automatically look after your
own there was a true spirit of equality
perhaps in this country from say 1900 to
1970
and i think cash has transformed that
you know greed has become good to quote
gordon gekko sure and what about our
approach and attitude towards mental
health has that changed positively
well i i think as i
the way we treat mental illness very
much reflects the way we treat our
society and each other
you know dostoevsky famously said that
you can judge a civilization by the way
it treats its prisoners but you know i
think you should judge a civilization
where we treat people having breakdowns
depression and sadness
you see for all the advances we've had
in drugs and some forms of therapy which
are very effective ultimately the most
important thing is to show these people
understanding kindness
and provide them with a chance to engage
meaningfully with the world
for thousands of years we've
marginalized these people in some parts
of the world these people are nailed to
posts outside villages or slaughtered
even
in some places like this country we used
to stick them in the laces called
asylums these sprawling mansions as far
away from the city as possible but now
thanks to capitalism they're luxury
timeshare flats they're they're
beautiful
go check out free and barnett in the
north
of the north london so in a way what
we've done is we've like you know at the
expense of commercialism has occurred at
the expense of connection between us
and another thing is that
human beings are very inward looking you
know by nature especially the more
modern part of our brain that tells us
to to think about ourself
and increasingly you know i think we
think much more about us as individuals
as we do as who we are as people who are
connected to the world
it's like
if you like almost a shrinking of our
notion of what identity means
we now think it's okay to walk down the
street on a war protest with the phrase
not in my name
who cares about your name you know just
charlie you know
i was in the supermarket not so long ago
and it said they were selling their
plastic bags their lifelong plastic bags
in the supermarket for the school fact
that our selfishness is drowning the
planet and it said every time you want
to buy one of our lifelong bags the
planet says thank you
oh the planet is thanking me we like
that idea you see and that same crass
individualism
if you like introspection gone crazy has
now led to us constantly looking in and
finding names for our day-to-day
distress and sadness and anime and
isolation so people come to me saying
i'm sad doctor they say i've got adhd
or they say i've got bipolar
you know i want what he's got you know
suddenly
bipolar disorder become like the gucci
handbag of mental illness i want that
one i don't want schizophrenia i don't
want borderline personality disorder and
even worse i want dialectical behavioral
therapy doctor i want it for this
condition
my father abused me doctor
so
my job is now quite a challenge which is
to get them to take a step back look not
just on their comp private inward
construction of their illness
but to see how it connects to their
disconnection from the world their
relationships their loss of job
the horrible things that really did
happen to them in their childhood that
led to those assumptions
so if you like psychiatry is
increasingly i think besieged by
crass simplistic expectations of society
which now take the name of labels and
diagnostic forms it's a sense of
professionalism that everyone thinks
they have and maybe that's because of
google as well you know you type in your
symptoms and then you say you can't
become committed to this idea of what
you might have and then that almost adds
to it and then you kind of fulfill that
expectation that is a very interesting
point i mean
if we take google as a stand-in for the
entire expansion of information
let's just rewind 5000 to 50 000 years
ago our species evolved from the
savannas of africa and laterally spread
across the europe and the north and so
on
because
we lived in small hunter-gatherer bands
of about 150 people we ate the same
stuff we hunted the same ship pretty
much for thousands hundreds of thousands
of years our brain formed evolved over
that time to be very successful with
social bands
information by and large was tolerable
with the amount available
now we know that there is a deluge of
information it's getting crazier and
crazier and crazier
my hunch and it's hard to prove this
because it's hard to do
experiments on a thousand year basis in
the course of my lifetime you know i
mean we have to see the bigger picture
like the pharaohs did with the pyramids
but what happens i think now is that we
are living under a cognitive burden that
is straining us like it never has before
that will certainly account for the
disturbing rise in anxiety and
depression the astonishing number of
syndromes we all seem to classify our
illness by
the use of antidepressant drugs and this
unders the size and the weight of the
self-help bookshop section in
waterstones
if then if you've been to a bookshop
recently and compared the self-help
deepak chopra department with what it
was like 30 years ago it's a big
industry why because it makes money if
it bleeds it's good it gives you you can
get cash out of that
and i think the real focus of kindness
compassion community sharing being
together
which has hitherto been the best way to
muddle along with the horror of
schizophrenia or depression or major
depressive disorder or bipolar disorder
this is something i do daily
and uh you know it's a
it we need to connect more
to to treat that really i guess on that
connectivity part if we move towards
social media it's frequently suggested
that social media smartphones and
similar technologies
have a negative impact on our mental
health um but do you think that we are
kind of almost bombarded with more
stimulation than our brains can handle
and given that it's social media is here
to stay how do we approach a healthier
relationship with it
i do think that we are living in the
world where there is an increased
cognitive load that i by that i mean we
are giving ourselves too much
information to handle but there's a
problem here you see
because it's rather delicious you know
google is a really fancy use for gadget
wikipedia is a phenomenal construction
you know wikipedia is up there with the
great museums in the baghdad california
of 750 a.d and remember the muslims are
the first people to really bring vast
amounts of knowledge together long
before we went and set fire to mall
which is about 11th century
so you know i think information is very
very useful if used carefully but if you
actually look at what we really do on
social media you know i'm not
particularly interested to know that my
friends just had a really nice cup of
coffee in a cafe in in a garden in
stuttgart
you know that's not particularly useful
but if you look at what we're really
doing it's porn and blather that's
really the truth of how we're using most
of it
used judiciously
i think we could have a use it as the
true gift it is
sure and it seems to me you know there
is so much distress at the moment and
that's coupled with the fact that
there's still a lot of political
indifference surrounding these topics um
why is so much suffering still met with
this reaction and what more could be
done by the government do you think
the lives of others basically are never
as interesting as the lives of ourself
if we're living in a selfish world
and i think that
what we really have here is the fact
that we don't really like to face up to
the things that cause us discomfort we
run away from them it's natural daniel
kahneman puts his brilliant in his book
thinking fast and slow it's a compendium
of the lies we tell to ourselves to stay
sane right
but when we are confronted by bad things
there are some things that really carry
the headlines god sex death bodily
fluids maybe estate agents
and mother-in-laws but the real one the
real killer joking aside is madness
the idea that someone might do something
for no reason at all
and that is really quite unsettling i
cannot predict this person's behavior
from what i know to be their normal
humanness
madness stirs something deep inside us
and in the west the idea that we're not
rational beings which i take for granted
as my profession is profoundly shocking
and that's why we've always
gassed them drowned them put them on
hills as far away from towns as possible
and we're still doing that the same
today but the geography is now in our
heart rather than on a hill and that's
reflected in our funding it's reflecting
that mental hospitals are always at the
end of that corridor in the hospital we
have mental health services we have this
stupid word mental illness
if i went to a gp with a sore elbow and
he said yes your elbow's got a physical
illness
i changed my gp
but we're quite happy with the idea that
there's this thing called mental
versus physical and that's because of a
crazy frenchman who came up with what we
thought was a good idea
to bring a descarte 500 years ago and he
said
it's about me i think therefore i am
i am what is the question really what
are we connected to
we're living breathing eating members of
a network and who we love and what we
love and what we cherish and value
define us as much as who we are and
we've lost sight of that so we're all
going crazy well to end on you know a
more positive note what do you think is
something that fills you with confidence
or hope about the future
youth
kindness and the fact that being able to
our biggest capacity as human beings is
our empathy if you think about it every
cheesy hollywood movie take jack black
in holiday for example you know it ends
with him and kate huggling around the
sofa with we know whoever it was you
know all the movies usually end with a
notion of coming together through found
commonalities
it's really really common it's in about
a boy it's in four weddings and a
funeral richard curtis made a fortune
out of this cheesy sort of stuff but
what it really tells us is that
connecting like ian foster said only
connect
is the thing that human beings are
programmed to do far better than log on
to instagram
so i think that's going to happen the
other thing is that we've got this small
thing called the extinction of the
planet coming up
and that's capping because of our
selfishness and our inability to see the
big [ __ ] picture stupid excuse my
language that's what it boils down to
it's that serious
and the next generation
and an extinction rebellion to whom
everyone should be saying vast amounts
of money as far as i'm concerned
i think are going to try and make that
clear
and we're going to have a real mess but
ultimately
i think human ingenuity kindness and
hope will um pull it all together mark
salter thank you very much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv
you